hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend
joined I'm going to switch it up now by
Matt Gourley oh I go first you go first
I'm nervous yeah don't worry that's all
there is and Son of obsession hi and uh
I'm back
I'm gonna try again you're gonna try
again now we uh
I I've been mentioning a couple times on
the podcast recently that I did a bunch
of recordings when I was uh in New York
City and that includes the guest today
was recorded in New York City and what
happens when you record in New York City
is when we're here in La we get together
at this cool clubhouse that we have here
on the Larchmont area
of uh kind of central Hollywood and um
that's this is our Lair this is like if
you know that place the Joker hangs out
in that's got lots of you know jokery
things in the background or if the
Riddler hangs out there there's lots of
question marks you don't want to go with
like the Specter volcano from James Bond
that Blowfish no I'm gonna stick with
this all right I know you're using a lot
of villains um well I do think of myself
as a villain a comedic villain but
um
uh or penguins in like an ice cave with
lots of penguins this is you would this
is a a Conan layer yeah we're in right
now and
um it's very comfortable and cozy when
I'm in New York I go to the SiriusXM
offices uh which are in Midtown to do
the recordings and when you walk in uh
you've you can back me up on this uh uh
Adam Adam sacks is here who's the Evil
Genius behind everything we do he's the
one pulling the puppet strings
um Adam you're aware that you walk in
and there's this big kind of Atrium and
there's a giant screen and a big
wrap-around couch and it's a very large
kind of festive area and it's packed
it's packed with people who were coming
to do recordings on for Sirius it's like
a combination Lobby so people who are
just there for meetings or for work uh
and also for people who are for talent
who's coming in to go guest on podcasts
three times radio three times I walked
into the building and there's just a
whole bunch of uh you know I don't know
I don't know who they are
but uh just packed with
entourages and I'm being introduced to
people and it's like
this is little boogie oh and uh you met
little boogie I met little boogie you
made me have a little boogie yeah yeah
you know or I'll walk in and it's always
like nine bodyguards you know what I
mean and everyone's uh you know
everyone's all decked out in various
kinds of costumes and then uh lots of
rappers I think lots of rappers
um and everyone seems happy to see me
which is nice and they'll come up and
they'll say mad respect and so I I would
just say right back at you
and then they'll say you know you know
uh uh Admiral Chaz and um
[Music]
no formerly little buggy formally he's
now Admiral Chaz oh my God okay yeah you
know whether you're on a cross-country
drive or on your daily commute time in
the car is perfect for listening to
podcasts like I don't know this one
T-Mobile covers more highway miles with
5G than anyone their Network helps keep
you connected to all your favorite
podcasts when you're out and about I
gotta tell you I like to road trip
sometimes I do too and I have T-Mobile
and I ca I can honestly say there's
coverage that's important like there's
been times in my life where I'm out on
the road driving around and uh
especially on those family trips you're
out in the desert you want to make sure
you have that coverage yeah what if you
get like your car breaks down and you're
just there sitting there like a chump
yeah no coverage yeah not this guy I've
got T-Mobile got 5G find out more at
t-mobile.com Cy that's
s-e-e-w-h-y but anyway I just feel kind
of overwhelmed because I think I have to
get my
I need to catch up I want to be able to
walk into a room and know instantly who
everybody is but don't you see that you
could have had an Entourage if you
brought us with you and yet again
these were entourages
no no no these are you know who put on
sunglasses no inside well by you really
get in there though with these
entourages though I walked out of the
bathroom at one point you were
surrounded by one of the entourages and
you were making did you know who it was
I didn't know who it was and I'm getting
lots of hugs and um being told mad
respect so I started saying mad respect
oh and at one point I think I was
talking to someone who was just there to
fix the air conditioning and I was
telling them mad respect but um I just
need to I need to know what's happening
I mean I got a big boost because my
daughter took me uh to um Coachella yeah
last uh summer and it it gave me a good
you know like I saw a lot of bands but
it's you've got to really I mean in my
age you've got to really work at it you
have to take out some 70s like cop show
info to make room for that stuff or okay
um that's a that's valuable knowledge of
which presidents in the 60s and 50s made
which Supreme Court appointments there
you go that has to come out that maybe
comes out and then new people come in oh
no no I have no you have to make room
because you have to make room you know
it would just be uh fantastic entourages
are fleeting though you know what I need
from now on Adam I need prep when I'm
going to work it's serious I need
someone to prep me because I'm walking
in and it's just not gonna work
Eduardo come on no sir no seriously
would you know who everyone was uh
probably not everyone but I I guess I'd
probably know more than the table I
probably know all of them and also you
know it's just it's just one of those
things where I you know of course yeah I
know I knew no no no no no no they
weren't holding banjos oh they weren't
no okay then no one had no one had a
loot no one had a zither uh
[Laughter]
I will say this I will say this this is
just completely random but
um just file this under you never know
where you're going to meet talented
people I was I was going to take a walk
up through Central Park and meet a
friend of mine and I'm walking up the
west side and I realized oh I um I don't
have any sunblock on and it's really
sunny out today and you know that
doesn't go well for me Sonic you've been
with me when I you start to smell bacon
cooking so uh when I'm in the Sun for
more than five minutes yeah so one of
those those places blew Mercury yes I
see one of those when I go in and
um this young woman uh says can I help
you and I go I'm just looking for some
sunscreen and she really quickly found
me this great sunscreen and she talked
me out of getting tinted she went no you
don't want tinted you just get this she
was great and so I started chatting with
her and she didn't know she didn't know
who she's very young she didn't know who
I am or anything other people in this
she noticed that other people in the
store knew who I you know who I am so
she said oh do you and I said yeah I
know I work in television stuff he said
well I'm I work on I'm a recording
artist but I'm I'm really working on it
and then I said well let me see what
you've got and she starts showing me her
videos and she's great and she's doing
all these synchronized dances on these
very professional and her name is TK and
she was great and I thought you know
you're gonna I just want to give a shout
out to TK who who put uh I mean she sold
me so it just was so inspired by her
because she showed me a bunch of her
videos and then I mentioned her to my
daughter who started looking up more for
videos and she said she's really good
and uh maybe you discovered her she gets
all these uh her friends to help her out
who were dancers and she has these very
professional looking uh
um you know dance synchronized dance
moves and you should introduce her to
little boogie yeah and Admiral Chaz yeah
yeah did you make her sign a contract
that if she becomes big then you get a
piece of whatever I made her I asked I
made her sign a contract that if she
gets big she has to buy me uh one tube
of sunscreen one tube Conan could ask
for more than sunscreen trust me you
know life's been good to me but I'll
never have enough sunscreen no it's just
TK is uh she was I don't know I was very
impressed with her and I thought that's
cool if I remember
um you know my brain is failing rapidly
but if I remember I'll give a shout out
to my friend who works at Blue Mercury
kind of Midtown just uh Central Park
South
um
who uh helped out a struggling rapidly
burning Conan O'Brien did you find TK uh
found its TK t-k-a-y
think this is her yes that's her that's
TK well I'm glad you got sunscreen yeah
you need it yeah thanks I'm really
really really need it well we don't need
to do that or you'll die well yeah it's
the slowest moving cancer skin cancer
here we go oh god oh man sorry to bum
everyone out it just means it's easy
just get checked out everybody I get
checked out every 30 minutes
hahaha